the beloved Bioware developed Star Wars
Knights of the Old Republic is being
treated to an unreal engine for remake
with new missions worlds and more I'm
Kate and this is your GameSpot news
update as phi ren the title of the
Knights of the Old Republic reboot is
being developed by indie gaming group
poem studios with help from fans of the
Star Wars RPG the appearin website
answers a couple of questions that
interested players might have liked is
making a Star Wars game like this legal
according to the remakes developer the
game being made is totally fine while
selling it isn't that means when the
remake releases it'll be 100% free the
developers aren't looking for donations
yet though we are looking to have a
larger portion of the game finished and
polished before there is any kind of
monetary backing they wrote on their
website there's not any video just yet
although the team have been
live-streaming the game's development on
Twitch do you think this Star Wars
project will get off the ground or will
Disney clamp down on it like an iron
door on a rancor let me know in the
comments or come and find me on Twitter
I'm at how not to draw thanks for
watching and for all your gaming and
entertainment news keep it GameSpot